welcome to the episode of get close I'm
Geo I'm Bart and what are we talking
about today Bart today we're talking
about finances what do you know about
finances bro not very much because I'm
an idiot but I've learned a couple
things along the way like what
so recently on Instagram I posted hey
what do you guys want us to talk about
and a lot of people actually want to
learn about finances Investments yada
yada and I think it's because a lot of
the demographic is aging right like
people that are 18 or turning 19 people
24 20 25 so they're moving into that
next bracket that new phase in life from
high school to College college to like
early working early work into like young
families buying their first homes and
stuff
and like oh you know when it's been so
red like when I meet people that watch
our content they're like I grew up on
you guys and I'm like that is so [__]
tight yeah they go I've been watching
you since junior high and they have a
full [__] beard I'm like what the
[__] the point is that they've seen us
grow and they've seen our life grow and
just kind of the lifestyle that we live
and
um and they admire that and they're like
cool like that's inspiring yeah so it's
really cool that you're about to share a
bunch of the steps that we've taken
um to move into our next phase in life
because we've moved in phases like we
were in high school that went to college
College to start up our own [__] super
[__] broke and then got super [__]
money and then lived super [__] dope
and then going ooh what do we want and
what don't we want and what's the next
phase because now we're getting old I'm
about to be 40 bruh isn't that crazy it
is crazy and I don't feel 40. that
doesn't even bother me honestly like the
number doesn't bother me at all because
I know me well that's your problem son
um it doesn't bother me at all because
that's what I'm saying thank you
well that and I don't feel 40 right like
I don't move like a 40 year old I don't
even know what that's supposed to be
like but I just I feel so young I put
chapstick on your vagina
do I was it dry do I
I did hear it cough like
hey you have a baby and then [__]
have it be [__] dripping wet and you
also look like you're 40. so maybe you
work on yourself no you look great too
looking good these days yeah so whenever
I hear that 40 comment it doesn't bother
me ever but there is definitely I do
feel a shift in my life happening where
I'm like yeah I ain't trying to work
like this yeah yeah so
um before I get into the way I like to
do things
um I always like to shout out the actual
experts the gurus so the people that I
listen to religiously is uh Graham
Stefan uh minority mindset
Bigger Pockets
and Dave Ramsey thatch that you in with
the real estate because you're always
texting him that's true so those are
probably the main five um if there's
someone else I'll remember to put the
name in
um right after but if you guys want
expert information
these are the five guys and I would say
the reason why you would want to maybe
listen to what I have to say and can
take from it is because these guys are
experts and sometimes they're a little
bit unrelatable and they're giving
information at too high of a level I
feel like I'm like a newbie a new a
newbie you know so sometimes like the
blue belt can teach a white belt better
than a black belt can for sure yeah so
because you you don't know how much you
know so you're explaining at such a high
level that you might be forgetting the
in-between steps yeah and I literally
was just a white belt so I'm like oh I
could tell you some of the struggles I
literally went through like last week
okay so I would say
um our entire Finance investing Journey
um well I got a shot on my mom too then
because uh as a kid I think that because
a lot of the things that you do as an
adult is a result of some of the habits
you built as a kid and I remember as a
kid I would always get like Chinese New
Year's money birthday money stuff like
that and my mom never let me spend it so
I actually hated her for that during
that time because like all my friends
can go and buy stuff that they want like
a Nerf gun or whatever where are they
now I don't know I don't
know
um
actually one of them became Graham one
scrum Stefan now that's good
and uh I just hated that you know but
one of the habits that she built with me
is back then there was no ATMs you would
go to the bank
oh my there was no ATMs you have to go
in the bank in person and talk to a
teller ATM is a new thing bro okay go
ahead maybe you worked it because I
remember being in elementary school and
there was drive-through ATMs yeah you're
40.
yeah you're [__] 39 don't act like
you're [__] 20 years younger than me
where no ATMs at that time the ATMs is a
new thing that came out when I was like
in Middle School
sure when I was like in first grade
there were no ATMs all right fine now I
gotta look this [__] up go so we had to
go in and then to talk to a teller and
they would give you a banking uh booklet
do you remember that it looks like a
passport yeah where Mexicans are
probably poor so you never had anything
like that but there's a banking booklet
and so it's like a passport that's hard
cover and it looks like an official
document so every time we would go in we
would deposit money and they would take
that thing and then scan it through the
the thing and print out almost like a
new balance every single time why do you
have sour lips uh so by the 1980s these
money machines had become widely popular
and handled many of the functions
previously performed by human tellers so
if you were born before the 80s then
I'll give you that but you were well
into the [__] 90s well they weren't
rolled out then okay buddy go look up
when the [__] a debit card was first
issued debit card is different you need
a debit card no you don't no you don't
how do you access the ATM you do not
need a debit card how do you access it
uh you can have access one right now
no you can have a it's called like a
savings card like a bank card but it's
not a debit card because a debit card
denotes that it has like a Visa or
MasterCard logo that now you can pay in
different [__] stores so debit is
different you don't even know about
Sumitomo bank I don't care about
simitamo Bank
go you [__] okay so we just have this
these banking booklets so I hated my mom
but we've developed these habits it
would go and save money and I Remember
by the time I was like 10 opening it one
day and it said like three grand in it
and I'm like Oh my mom did that for me
too oh that's why we we needed to do
that so I hated my mom for 10 years but
you're smart because saved so much money
then you're smart because you saw that
as a valuable thing and going yay my mom
would deposit 20 bucks into all her kids
accounts every single month so when I
finally got my savings card because
that's all I had a savings yeah she had
about two thousand dollars say for me
and I was like [__] let's go buy dumb
[__] yeah well for me I think she built
the habits that's the thing you gotta
exercise and do it she took me to the
bank oh no mine was just showed up and
it just yes
and we lived in Cerritos and we're drive
to Monterey Park because that was where
the only I think like Asian Banks were
so it was like a whole thing like okay
we had to go do this I'm doing that with
taika now he doesn't hate me yet no but
you let him spend it which is good oh
right right but I'm also I'm breaking it
up for him yeah so it's not really about
the spending we're saving it's the
action of being uh financially present
you know like looking at the money don't
want to give some away you don't want to
save it's that making those decisions
not the actual saving that
um creates the financial intelligence so
my mom helped me build those Habits by
doing those things and then
um when I got older and I started
getting like an um uh allowance my mom
would always go save hat save half so
every time I got like 20 bucks I put 10
bucks here and 10 bucks into like
another thing how did you what's another
thing what's another thing oh so
remember how like uh checking books came
in that like little carton yeah so in my
drawer I would take the top and the
bottom and put it like that next to each
other would your mom count to make sure
I put 10 bucks in this one and 10 bucks
in this one you know and watch them just
Stack Up and how they like change how do
we
maybe like a late elementary junior high
damn I would never why I just wanted to
spend it all and I would because my dad
would do the same [__] but he wouldn't
give me allowance yeah it would just be
whenever he felt like oh I hadn't given
this [__] money he'd give me like 20
bucks or 10 bucks
excuse
me and then he would say like hey make
sure to always have money in your wallet
and I never did yeah because I spent it
all yeah no we I would try to like watch
it Stack Up and once it got to like a
certain amount it would go to the uh
bank and deposit it that's awesome so
like once again building happens and
always uh saving half saving half yeah
so then later on when I started watching
like different Financial channels and
they're like say 10 or 20 or 30 of your
earnings that was easy because my mom
set the bar so high you know and then
she set the barcel highway save half
yeah because that was 50 yeah and the
Ballers that I looked up to like Jay-Z
always said if you can't afford to you
can't afford one so if you want to buy a
Rollie can you buy two if you can't you
can't even afford it yeah because you
should be spending money that is like
negligible that disposable to you so
those things just align so starting with
I would say like I started making real
money probably
um 2013.
maybe a 2012 2013 with JK yeah and um it
was easy for me to just immediately
start saving and putting money away and
then as soon as I had money that was
more than I knew how to spend because
you know like your lifestyle grows with
the amount of money right so at that
time like we just had like a regular car
like a you had a Honda Accord I had like
a Durango or whatever
and so
um with my mom teaching me these little
habits early on
it was easy for me to go okay
what's the first thing I should do I
should start investing in a time period
that I am completely not prepared for so
every single time we met with our CPA
and he was saying like how much do you
want to put into your retirement account
I always go full amount it could be
because number one so this is one big uh
one first I would say key item
when you have a retirement account
depending on the state
you always have a maximum amount that
you get to put away into that pre-tax
and you want to take advantage of this
because you are going to so like when
you get money like let's say 100 bucks
when you get taxed it turns into 70
right if it gets taxed at 30 so now you
have to deal with uh only 70 and you
pretty much just lose out on the 30. yep
but if you're able to move money aside
pre-tax so like let's say you can move
30 bucks now you only have to get taxed
on the 70 and that 30 bucks is still
yours it's not 30 that turned into 20
it's 30 that's still yours I get to use
later so
um with retirement as early as I can
I've always been put into my brain
when you're able-bodied you want to
start setting yourself for when you're
not abled body so every single year for
JK my taxes and your taxes always the
full amount I want to deduct that's able
to be pre-tax money and put that away
now to this day which is like
um 10 years later
yeah almost like 10 years later our
retirement account has almost a million
dollars in it which is pretty [__]
crazy I know and I've never missed a
single one of that money that went in
there yeah I'm never like oh man yeah so
that's one thing that like money can
grow fast especially when they put into
those retirement accounts what's the
compounding interest right yeah they're
technically like like almost like mutual
funds or like ETFs they're like just
these they're technically buying like a
really safe stock so the more time you
can put behind you the more time you
have for it to grow because like Apple
stock if you look at whatever it is 10
years ago versus what it is now it's way
less when it's great to be able to put
money away when you can yes if you're
able to do it yes well not even Able
Body because able-bodied meaning that
you can still earn it I'm saying you're
living a lifestyle that allows you to
even save right because like you can be
remember when we were starting we
couldn't afford [__] gas there's no
way we're saving we still had I still
had debt yeah like how am I gonna save
money when I still have debt like that
doesn't make any [__] sense yeah yeah
and then I also learned like one of the
biggest things with finances is learning
like loophole I'm not even loopholes but
learning strategies yes so with the
retirement account I have also learned
you can technically you can't crack it
open until you're 55 or 60 or 65
depending on the state right if you do
then you have to pay the penalty fee and
then you have to pay taxes on it because
you move the money pre-tax into there
but if you have a if you're able to take
it out and put it back in with the same
month did you know you have zero fees I
don't remember that so that's one of the
key things so that's why it's like when
you when you look into these different
funds or any type of Investments
look at the Strategic implications
because that because now you're banking
yourself you know when you're like
looking at something I really want to
buy that house but that deal has to
happen now if I don't make it happen now
then
um
I'm gonna lose out on this crazy
opportunity the 10x well guess what if
you're very sure about this
if you can get this million dollars out
make this deal happen make the money and
put it back in you technically just
banked yourself for 30 days which is
something that is amazing you know so
like being able to know like okay not
just like
save into a but a can also mean b c d e
that is where like the true Finance
strategies come in so
um the retirement account has a million
bucks but technically we're also able to
bank ourselves a million bucks if
anything happens and also I also learned
if uh and also I've also learned yeah
and also I've also learned that also if
you have a family emergency and then
that makes you tap into your retirement
account you don't have to pay attention
I think you can do that also with your
life insurance that one too which I'm
like what so there's a lot of like those
things that are very very helpful that
you should look into so for those of you
guys I would say step number one
um I always look at my my life uh my
finance life my life a quarter mile at a
time yeah
um and it's all about family no I always
look at um my life in buckets like
what's my now bucket what's my 10-year
bucket and then what's my retirement
Bucket look like and then making sure
I'm putting deposits in all of them and
then so a lot of times that just
naturally uh spills over spills over and
has a parallel into risky Investments
medium safe Investments and extremely
conservative Investments I mean it's the
same when you're saving too like you can
save for uh you can have a bucket for
your play money a bucket for your
donation money a bucket for your toys
Money a bucket for the saving investment
blah blah blah yeah so with that being
said I have my stuff that's covered for
us way down the line I know we have at
least a million dollars now waiting for
us for when we turn 55 or 65.
by the time we get there and we don't
add any more money in
like just in 20 years
that money is gonna probably turn into
like 10 or 20 million you know I mean
because we got we started got started so
young and started putting so much away
at such a young age yeah so the latter
half of our life we're set we don't have
to worry about it because we're gonna
have our house all of that yeah knock on
wood nothing happens with the [__] us
yeah but our retirement account that we
set ourselves up really good it's going
to be like 10 20 million in the future
so now speaking into the immediate
present one of the most important things
um that you'll hear any like Financial
Guru talk about is having three to six
months of operating expenses that's what
I would say is like your first name
because your job you can lose at any
time even your business like we own
business you can lose it at any time of
course anything we saw what the [__]
covet like we were shut down from one
day to the next that's it that's it you
make no more money yeah we've seen stock
markets crash Bitcoin crash all kinds of
things crash so the thing that you need
the most liquid is Cash because you have
to be able to buy groceries it's awesome
that you got so many stocks but can you
buy milk for your baby you know that's
what's most important so I would highly
recommend three to six months of
operating inspections so that includes
your rent or your mortgage your car
payments like everything you need to
live life your cell phone your grocery
bill your utilities everything so that
like if you lose a job you're literally
unaffected for three to six months so
that way you can
um lose your job get be get put in the
worst situation but don't have to worry
about financial stresses and then that
way you can have Full Speed Ahead to get
back on your feet versus if you lose
your job and now you can't make payments
you have you're like double [__] because
you're in a corner with with two hard
things to deal with
so for us we have that that I never
touch so that's like number one we
always have our operating expenses three
to six months that we never ever touch
and that kind of Falls in line with uh
the Dave Ramsey
baby steps he's extremely conservative
not politically
but he doesn't even believe in debt or
loans and I kind of like that because
well there's a lot of other people that
have different strategies right like
Robert uh
Kiyosaki that is about I only want to
work with debt he only wants good debt
that's all he wants yeah but the problem
is
um I think it's like the baby and the
candy
like it just depends right I mean it's
not one not one shoe fits all yeah like
if you're the type of person you can
have a donut sitting next to you all day
long and you know oh that's bad for you
I'm not gonna eat it there's those
people then go ahead and play with that
but for me I think most people have a
hard time controlling themselves which
is why as a nation we're overweight as a
nation we're in debt why like our credit
is so [__] in this country I think
Dave Ramsey actually has a really good
approach because he's like just get the
donut out of here yeah stop playing with
the [__] donut so he has like uh you
know he has like seven baby steps his
first one is um save a thousand bucks
every month no no just have a thousand
as an emergency oh because I think a lot
of people what was the statistic I think
like 70 of the population at least in
the U.S are not prepared
um to for an emergency that's more than
like 600 exactly like they cannot afford
that so so many people are living life
like this right teeter-tottering on the
on the brink of like collapse so for him
he's like just have the psychology to be
able to
have a thousand bucks and he goes if you
don't have it
in the next 30 days this is something
you should be able to accomplish so
whether get a second or third or fourth
a fifth job or sell everything that you
don't need in your garage
babysit do whatever it washed cars but
have the mindset and the ability that if
I need a thousand dollars and 30 days I
can do it so that's step number one step
number two
is once you have that I think it's the
then it's the um oh I pay off all debt
and then he has this thing called the
snowball method which I like which is
start with because there's an avalanche
method and snowball method Avalanche
method is the biggest balance pay that
off because that is accruing the most
interest right against your favor and
then go slowly down to the one that you
only owe like 50 bucks on for him he
goes do the snowball method start with
the smallest because it's all about the
psychology of money yeah yeah because
then you start seeing it dwindle away
and you're done and you get better and
you're motivated better and better yeah
when you set the first hurdle so high
it's hard to build momentum you don't
see it going down fast enough yeah so if
you have five credit cards boom boom
boom boom boom feels good versus it
taking forever to pay down the ten
thousand and then you have the four
other ones waiting exactly so snowball
so second one is no debt then third is
the three to six months expenses and
then I think the fourth one is uh
retirement starting to save for
retirement fifth one I think is
investments in homes six one that being
is paying off the home uh and the
seventh one is like starting so before
starting to help your family are you
sure he wants it that way it could be I
could okay because it sounds like the
way he is conservative it sounds like he
wants you to pay that off beat that free
and then at that point you can start
your investment properties
yeah so that's the part where I'm kind
of mixed up a little bit because uh I
know for him retirement is me and him on
the same page in terms of retirement you
make it sound like he's your uh he's
your homie here are the baby steps that
anyone can do yes baby step number one
save a thousand dollars for uh for your
starter emergency fund baby step number
two pay off all debt good job you have
great memory except the house using the
debt snowball damn you're good uh baby
step number three save three to six
months
um of expenses in a fully funded
emergency fund
uh baby step number four invest 15 of
your household income into retirement
good job baby step number six pay off
your home early that's the one and then
baby step number seven is build wealth
and give and help people around you yeah
damn you good so the reason why it was
so easy for me to memorize that was it
makes sense no it's because that's how I
approached our finances like when I came
across
um I mean it seems intuitive and I came
across the Dave Ramsey seven baby steps
the first time I saw it I was like okay
Bart Ramsay that's literally what I did
because remember we paid we've given
we've been giving my mom two thousand
dollars a month allowance yeah we pay
for my mom's car for like 10 years yeah
we bought your mom two cars now like
like we've been we've already been on
baby step seven you know for our house
the only thing that we did differently
when we came up the million bucks we're
going to we were going to pay off the
house
um but I forgot what it was but it had
to do with like the market whatever so
we ended up buying just other real
estate and then now letting that income
pay for this mortgage which now we have
that and more yeah and which I think was
a blessing in disguise because once the
market turns around
now we have four properties that are
able to gain equity
which if you understand the finance game
like you could get helocs cash out refi
just all these things where more just
different terms of being able to bank
yourself worst case scenario you sell
off one of the properties get that money
do whatever you need yeah so you have
liquid cash so just to kind of like
um every single bit I want to kind of
like con concisation consolidate
consolidate and summary and summarize
just so that uh summarization I know
when it comes to finance it could be
like a very hard to grasp things so
number one we talked about
um as soon as you can save uh yeah save
put that away number two
when you're able body and you have the
money try to put away for retirement
because you trust me 10 10 years gonna
go by like that just like us and I
randomly pull up our retirement accounts
here and there I'm oh [__] that's a lot
of money yeah we're good you're gonna
thank yourself in the past and then um
three is the emergency fund starting to
have that so now once you have like
those main things and then pay off debt
debt is a killer it's a falcon killer
because if you've ever been in debt we
both have when you make two grand and
you gotta put 500 bucks immediately away
to like a credit card because you're
paying like 23 25 30 yeah it's imp it'll
it feels almost impossible to stack your
chips like that when
two grand is immediately well two grand
and then 500 is taxes and another 500 is
credit card bills now you're only stuck
with the grand well and it's just bad
practices right like to be spending
money when you owe a ton of money yeah
you know like it just doesn't make sense
like if nothing is paying for that other
thing like if it's not a strategy that
you're working and it's just it's just
bad money management yeah like the way
that I like to view it is trying to row
the boat as hard as you can when you
have a hole in it yeah so water is
constantly going in so what you want to
do is actually plug it and then now when
you rode the boat it's that much easier
so if you have debt pay that off as
rapidly as you can because you're gonna
be like oh [__] I could actually [__]
breathe yeah and then
um then you could take your time with
all the other steps because with debt
you can't take your time because every
single month you have to pay the minimum
yeah and one other key term that I
learned uh that applies to crypto stocks
and real estate because I think everyone
that studies the market now which I
think um I don't want to say the average
like 20 to 30 year old is more
financially intelligent because if I
Financial intelligence to me comes from
your results I think they're more
financially aware
so for the reason why I say that is a
lot of the people that I know that are
like mid-20s late 20s they talk about
finances a lot a lot more than I did
when I was in my 20s
um but are they making the right actions
we don't know yet right because it's
it's hard it's like still you're still
young and you're still trying to figure
[__] out but the key the term that has
helped me the most is called Don't time
the market it's about time in the market
so everyone always feels like oh [__]
it's the wrong time I should have bought
Bitcoin it was a thousand I could have
bought a house when this was happening
should have bought that whatever that
was happening and it's always these big
things that they should have done
but every single investor I ever talked
to they said the best time to invest was
yesterday the second best time is today
because as soon as you can put time
behind you that's how you let your
Investments grow so even if you're
buying a a piece of a stock a piece of a
Bitcoin a piece of ethereum or even
um with real estate they have real
estate stocks called REITs it's like
it's instead of buying a whole house you
could actually buy into a market and go
I'll put like 5g's in here or whatever
and it's the same thing and as that
market grows you reap the benefits of
that appreciation so being able to
develop the habit of okay you know what
maybe every month I'll put away 50 bucks
100 bucks a thousand it's not about the
instant gratification it's not about the
fast results is how much little can I
put away and put as much time behind me
as possible so like you know when you go
on Zillow and you look at homes you're
like dude that thing's 500 Grand right
now then you scroll down there's always
a graph and you're like what the [__]
that thing was 80 grand at one point
it's like yeah just over time it's like
pillow money that guy is still doing his
regular job yeah but because he was able
to buy early on yeah this thing grew so
much so imagine the same person that's
buying it for 500 right now we've seen
the homes in La go from 500 to like 2
million over the course of like two
decades so that's the other thing that
is really really important with crypto
with everything so now yeah so now with
our crypto little fun
um I have a set so I don't think about
it and every day it just buys a little
bit
and then it's actually helped me out
psychologically because right now we are
in a market like uh downturn so it's
like bear market and so I almost feel it
as like oh combine it as at a savings
because you know the cheaper like let's
say Bitcoin is yeah the same amount that
I'm buying I get to buy more
but then what's cool is once Bitcoin
starts growing all the ones I bought in
the last year now two three four five x
yeah yeah so I think it's also knowing
what Market you're getting into and how
it grows in over time how it how it
grows right because you're always
talking about dollar cost averaging yes
like all the time and um it can be a
daunting term but it really is you just
studying the market for like decades at
a time because it going up and down up
and down is normal like I remember being
super young and then us having a housing
crisis this is before the crazy uh the
crazy
um market crash that we had in 2008 I
believe yeah
um when my dad was still alive and he
like I remember I didn't know enough
about homes and finances and stuff but I
remember my dad like everyone's freaking
out but my dad would be like what are
they freaking out about this happens
every 20 years like look at the history
this is bound to happen and it always
goes up and down like nothing is ever a
linear thing nothing's ever a straight
line so he's like we're gonna get out of
it you just have to keep sticking in it
I remember him saying that and that
still applies now like in anything that
you do it always has its up and downs
but it's literally what you're saying
right the dollar cost average yeah and
that actually applies to so many
different things so like uh even outside
of Finance outside of housing any point
anything you're trying to be successful
at you need to dollar cost average like
the same concept what is dollar cost
average so I'm not explaining right now
so like dollar cost average is doing a
little bit every single day versus doing
a ton at once because I think that's
what most people try to do right they go
okay I Gotta Buy Bitcoin everyone tells
you buy Bitcoin oh [__] Bitcoins 30 G's
okay I gotta say I gotta save until I
have like 30 G's and it keeps growing
and it keeps growing right
versus you know what I only have five
bucks I'll buy five bucks right now but
the habits it's about building the
habits that gets you success versus
trying to
um like test your success so in Fitness
and the reason why I like to draw the
parallels it's because it's so it's
still online it's what do you think is
better
doing 10 minutes versus like what do you
think is better doing 10 minutes worth
of sit-ups a day
or doing
300 sit-ups
what the [__] am I saying I don't care
what do you think is better 10 minutes
worth of sit-ups a day or 300 minutes
worth of sit-ups once a month
300 minutes first of sit again 10
minutes worth of sit-ups every single
day yeah or 300 minutes worth of sit-ups
once a month
um I would say because I know the I know
the answer I would say the 10 minutes a
day exactly and that applies to bench
that applies to cardio yeah everything
right because you're building the habits
you're actually improving and so it's
the same thing where a lot of people
they go
um
I'll just buy like 300 bucks worth
um I'll just buy 300 bucks worth of
crypto or stocks or retirement whatever
at the end of the month
but by the time you get there do you
know how much life happens flat tire
this thing happens I gotta pay for this
oh my car registration worth the 300
bucks is so hard it's so much easier
just to do the daily work
do 10 bucks 10 bucks a day versus 300
it's the same amount of money but when
you do it on a daily and habit building
it's way easier it's not as sexy and
yeah I just dropped 300 bucks on crypto
10 bucks is Gonna Get You way better
than the 300 so that's what the dollar
cost averaging is which is what is the
um average that I'm gonna that what is
the dollar amount that I can commit to
every single day and that will average
the market Cycles over time yeah yeah I
think that's the same thing with Fitness
what's the 10 minutes
worth of exercise that I can do
regardless if I'm sick or it's raining
or I have to do it at home what is
something you can commit to every single
day and if you do that for a whole month
you're going to see results versus
the person that randomly goes I'm gonna
do Runyan Canyon and run five miles in
one day but that's not gonna do much to
you yeah yeah
so yeah so I would say that piece
um is extremely important is uh the
investment but then doing it in a
the boring but the most proven and most
successful way
yeah so then at what point were you
because you said there was a shift right
where
initially we were going to pay off this
house with the million that we made and
we were just going to live rent free
what was the turning point where you
were like well wait a minute hmm
so this is where thatch really helped me
the minute so how that story played out
was
um when we bought our first Vegas house
there was like you know the gossip on
the streets dude I think our house is
going up the house is going up you know
remember I was like oh [__] for real for
real it's crazy and then so I already
know about helocs HELOC which is a home
equity line of credit which is the
appreciation of your house
um versus what you bought it for that
Gap like how much a loan how much the
value of the land has increased the
whole property how much that whole
property that appreciation how much has
that increased and you can take a loan
out against yourself and use that money
so for example if it appreciated like
let's say
um 200 Grand usually it's 80 so you can
pull out 160 like you have cash yes you
have to make payments on it because it's
technically a loan but you have 160 that
you can do to whatever business yeah
model the home do whatever with right
yeah because it's an asset your home is
an asset yes so when I found out that a
lot of the homes were going up in value
I'm like okay cool I'm gonna pull a
HELOC and one of the processes of a
HELOC to know how much your house
appreciated you have to get it appraised
so when it got appraised it came back
for like 2.8 and I was like oh [__]
that's because we got it at like one
point
one 1.2 1.3 so we got those from 1.3 so
the appraisal came back more than double
which is like 1.5 right so when we saw
that we're like okay that's [__] sick
and we didn't love the house which was
like double down yeah dip it down it was
a it wasn't as cozy as he wanted it to
be so we're like okay cool now the
strategy is going to be let's buy a
house that is under that 1.5 and then
that way when we sell this house it'll
pay for what we owe here and we'll have
enough money left money left over to pay
off the house that we're currently in
right now the problem is
um and this is like
this is why it takes experience
um the market started to turn because
there are the feds were bumping the
interest rate so as the interest rates
Rises generally the real estate market
slows down because it's harder to get a
loan so for example if you have a loan
at three percent uh versus a loan at six
percent it can change your monthly
payment from a thousand to like three
thousand bucks depending on how much
your house is
so the markets are to turn not as many
people wanted to buy and then so our
house we listed out to 2.8 2.7 2.6 we
have to drop the price and I think we
ended up selling for like 2.4 2.5 which
is still crazy good hell yeah it's still
like over a million bucks hell yeah
but now we're missing the one or two
hundred grand to go with the plan where
this one's just going to completely wipe
this one clean so now it's time to Pivot
and so that's kind of like all of
Finance right like or in life you're
trying to Pivot and always make the best
move with more data more information so
when we got hit with that I was like
okay if we can't if I can't pay off this
house and I also even uh hit up our loan
for this house and I was like What if I
pay off 90 and for some reason yeah the
payments are still really high I don't
know why it was but that's the way it is
well then I'm not going to give you all
that doesn't make sense so I'm like uh
then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna buy
that value worth of homes and if each
one of them is paying me like two to
twenty five hundred dollars rent because
they're completely paid off that'll
cover the mortgage of this house because
the mortgage of this house I think was
like five grand or something so I only
needed two or three homes to pay off the
mortgage of this house and so so that's
what caused me to change plans because
interest rates went up we didn't sell
the house for what we wanted to sell it
for was a little bit under it still came
up a million but now we have to just
kind of like pivot and stuff which is in
the long run I like it more
because it's that pillow money right
like we don't need it we didn't need it
like we could still comfortably pay for
this mortgage and now we're just
getting income on the side yeah and
that's the part that I want to stress
for everyone out there
um when you buy a home you are literally
banking yourself and that's why I was so
happy went with this route and I'm
actually happy that they bumped the
interest rates because now we own four
homes and three of them are pretty much
Banks and the reason why I say that is
when you have a home that is paid off or
if you have more Equity than what you
owe that Equity at any time you can cash
out refi so you can pull the money out
in equity and then refinance the home as
if you're going to buy it from scratch
or you can do a HELOC and when you have
money it's easy to get money you can
leverage things you know like you hear
bothers all the time oh I need money
um they'll literally go to like an asset
type of brokerage and go
for this rolly like how much money can
you give me I'll give you 20 G's they
have to come back with the 20s get the
Rollie back but when you have assets you
can you can leverage it and and you can
Bank yourself and so
um I'm happy because otherwise we've
already we would have just had one
property but now we have four properties
that we can technically Bank ourselves
with especially as the market grows like
all the properties that we got were
under
500 Grand but they're going to be 700
Grand one day so 700 times 3 that's now
2.1 million and this is not the end for
sure
yeah so when it comes to investing
um I also like kind of like the Warren
Buffett method where he likes to
diversify because any Market can tank at
any time so you just never know
so because um I think most of us none of
us are Financial gurus I think the
financial gurus obviously they're good
at finances because they're studying it
as much as a pastry chef is studying
pastries and well and what makes them a
guru right being in it yeah being in it
so I'm sure they have their portfolio of
a [__] ton of losses and mistakes and
bad Investments yeah but then the flip
to that is they have some that were
really [__] successful named Branson
repeat yeah so for me a lot of the stuff
that I hear I kind of take with the
grain of salt because I know it's very
hard to apply when it talks to when
you're talking to like the financial
gurus because they're in it it's almost
as if a pastry chef was teaching you how
to make your pastry and like yeah I just
do this all the time yeah it's easy no
yeah because if you have a commercial
kitchen yeah like I barely know how to
make a Pop-Tart so the way that I like
to view it is okay what's the Pop-Tart
way of investing and then so one of the
simplest ones that Warren Buffett does
he just kind of splits it like all
equally a little bit in real estate a
little bit in crypto a little bit and
like gold a little bit in liquid cash
because if a good investment pops up you
always want to be able to buy in
whenever you can and so uh and spend a
little bit more energy and money on the
stuff that relates to you more because
out of all the different Investments and
finances some things are going to come
very easy to people like oh I get stocks
oh I get crypto you know like Steve
um Anthony and Joe they love crypto it
just clicks they just like it yeah they
understand the internet World they
understand web3 they know blockchain to
me I'm like I don't know none of that
[__] so crypto I actually have the least
but I still have my finger in the pot my
[__] yes staring around because I
want to know what oh [__] trying to see
what's going on but what what I
understand the most is real estate
because I helped my mom rent her houses
before I understand like how to rent
tenants property managers I've seen my
mom remodel her house I'm like okay yeah
I know how long construction takes if
it's like this project takes like three
months I've been with my mom in a city
hall to get permits approved so I'm like
I quite understand real estate a lot so
that's why we have so much more in the
real estate realm for our investments
well and that just seems like it's the
the more stable of the ones you just
named off right like it's
uh the less riskier ones but it's also
the ones that don't give you the fastest
quickest rewards so for my because my
ass is [__] risk averse so the reason
why I like that so the reason why I like
real estate is
um the theme that makes the thing that
gives real estate a nice buffer is
actually the paperwork so crypto it's
like this
shoots up a thousand percent
you can go thing and literally liquidate
your Bitcoin ethereum whatever you have
instantly right so because of that the
swings are like this
so if you see a stock market crash you
see Fed bump interest rate the price of
that crypto is boom boom boom boom like
that right with real estate
fed bumps interest rates then people are
like oh [__] well it's harder to get a
loan that talking to your loan officer
takes two weeks okay I'm gonna list the
house you sell the house probably takes
two weeks to sell the house now you got
to go on escrow escrow takes another
three weeks so all the process and uh
procedures that you have to go through
creates like three month buffers all the
time yeah for you to cool off too yeah
which is why when they're studying like
real estate data they say the data that
you're looking at now is never the data
now it's always data from three months
ago which makes me feel good because
anytime there's a drastic change it
takes time for it to you know kind of to
go in so for me it's almost as if like I
get to be the captain of the ship and I
have a periscope and I can see what's
going you can see the iceberg way down
there versus I feel like in cryptos like
Iceberg Iceberg you know you're like oh
[__] oh [__] yeah yeah so for someone
that's risk adverse like me I like to
keep it cool and chill like that yeah
yeah that tends to be a lot of people
but I think also when things become
unpopular you can kind of get caught up
in the Whirlwind of like all my friends
are doing it and it seems like it yeah I
want to do it too you know but you
really have to know who you are and what
you want in the next five ten years to
be like wait is this a lining where I
want to be yeah I mean I've already been
to the crypto in 2017 with all the JK
dudes we bought OMG and all of us lost
at least 100 Grand
so I've been there you know so to me
these lessons I paid for yeah yeah you
paid the tuition oh [__] I don't know if
I like crypto that much then the second
time when all the boys got into Luna I
was like you know what maybe I should do
the Blue Chip crypto so I did mainly
Bitcoin ethereum
I was able to get away without losing
any money I broke even which is cool so
to me that's a success
attempt number one lost 100 G's attempt
number two break even attempt number
three hopefully uh now I'm like a really
dollar cost average a very little amount
we'll see what that pays off at the end
later on but hopefully it's like it's
all a learning curve you know yeah and
it's good if the learning curve is going
this way you don't want the learning
curve yeah that would suck you're not
learning [__] yeah but because of that I
learned I think real estate fits with me
a little bit more yeah that's so good
um what's in the works for the next year
because like I know for this year we're
pretty locked in with these three
properties because we just went so
aggressive with it what's the next phase
if there's even a next phase is it like
chill a little bit is it keep building
pull Equity from these houses what's the
next step so our financial I guess
portfolio as it stands right now we have
pretty much a million in retirement so
that's good that's also stocks because
the retirement is the stocks account
um we have our we pretty much have a
million dollars worth of real estate so
I think that that feels really really
good
we have some crypto
um under 100 G's worth and then we have
liquid but that liquid is mainly just
our reserves 36 month reserves so I
don't even count that we're not touching
that but now because we have all of our
real estate paid off I think passively
it's generating about like 8K to like 9k
a month now so if I if we wanted to and
we don't touch it which is the plan
it'll generate 100 G's a year so in five
years that'll be 500 G's you know which
is super cool so we have that coming in
so the next play is the rest of this
year I think we're Tapped Out
I want to fill up our Capital reserves
and then have the
um eight Jesus come in and we'll keep
stacking those chips but the next play
is what I'm waiting for and it depends
on what comes first if the interest
rates drop
I'm gonna immediately cash out refi the
other three properties because then
um I can take the cash out and have a
very small loan on it because the
interest rate is so low then I'll
aggressively buy again buy again yeah
um but if that doesn't happen anytime
soon then I'm just stacking Capital yeah
yeah so to me it's now about like
waiting for the market seeing what
happens to the market how does it
respond uh while we fill up our liquid
reserves to help I love it yeah no I
feel super secure I feel like we're
doing the right thing at least the stuff
that makes sense for us because I'm also
super risk adverse so anything that you
ever do want to bring up I always
um I have trust in your abilities to
research and and find the right things
and you're such a research junkie that
you not only research online but then
you hit up the experts and fortunate for
us we have access to experts so it's
really dope that you do tap into it
um that you never make a decision
without considering the family and
myself so you do your research and then
you present it to me and like whatever
it is that you present I'm always like
okay cool I get it if I don't get it
then at that point I'm like well wait
wait wait we gotta chill out I gotta
like make my own decision on this stuff
but
um everything you've presented I'm like
dude this all makes sense like let's do
that yeah and every and the way I like
to learn too
I like to be in the middle of the debate
you know I think that's the best way to
learn because like when you look at real
estate like that was like the thing in
the beginning when I first got into it
I'm like man what should I do should I
do like Airbnb everyone's doing Airbnb
or should I do long-term rentals because
that's what I know that's what my mom
did or should I do medium term rentals
or should I just do like flips I heard
people doing flips you know just get in
get out in like three months I also hear
people about wholesaling like off Market
deals like what is it like when you look
at it one of the best advice I got from
real estate agent shouts to Felicia
Rexford
she's also a real estate investor out
here in Vegas she was like every single
sector you're gonna find Millionaires
and billionaires public storage parking
lots you know a commercial Apartments
every single sector you're going to find
millions and billionaires so is there a
right way no it's Which Way best fits
you and you the only way to do it is get
your feet wet and go no this one isn't
for me oh this one comes very natural
I'll do this so it's getting your feet
wet little by little
um even going to meetups tagging along
with some friends seeing how your
friends are doing deals picking people's
brains and uh putting all that stuff
together so being in the middle of like
a think tank which is why like as much
as Dave Ramsey because I do relate to
him more as much of him I listen to I
listened to Robert Kiyosaki quite a bit
too because he's always talking about
debt and Loan and all that stuff and so
I want to hear what made him a
billionaire so I can understand what
made this guy a billionaire and then how
does that apply and how does that gonna
make me successful yeah yeah that's so
dope
I'm so lucky
because it's cool it's cool that you see
it that way and like you're such a
patterned person
um I remember attending a seminar with
Tony Robbins and he was saying like as
soon as you can figure out the pattern
to things you've unlocked a whole new
world and you just operate completely
differently so it's really dope that
that comes so naturally to you where you
see where you naturally see the pattern
of things because now you can start
predicting it and then once you
understand it the prediction comes and
then now you start creating your own
patterns which then turn into like
shortcuts and like just more sound ways
of of operating
um and and yeah like me finding the
patterns to things at least in certain
spaces I don't get it but then in other
Realms like you said whatever comes
naturally to you then I when I do get it
I'm like holy [__] this is tight because
now I can predict what these these
patterns will be if that makes any sense
no it makes perfect sense because that's
the first part that even got us the
first million in real estate to begin
with is I saw the patterns in cities
right I was like okay growing up the
cities you always hear about are always
master plan communities so like Irvine
but then Irvine is everything's over a
couple million dollars already and then
and why do like people like master plan
communities because the schools are
really really good and the roads are
really really nice and uh the community
areas feels extremely safe so I'm like
cool I just Google something simple
master plan communities and they're all
over the place Summerlin is one of them
but there's another one called inspirada
in Vegas and there's some in Texas
Florida like there's Mass communities
all over the place then it's easy to
just add top 10 top 20 master plan
communities you type you Google that and
boom they're like okay cool maybe I'll
look into real estate here so I look at
those real estate and you look at the
prices what is Affordable and then I
start going okay what are some of the
biggest complaints that people have
because when there's complaints that's
what makes people move traffic not
having uh international airport close to
them or if you're like me you have to
have an Asian supermarket you know so
you look at all those things and then
I'm like dude Summerlin is a no-brainer
right now it's extremely undervalued I
could totally see why people would want
to move to someone because it's 20
minutes away from one of the biggest
airports in nation and international
airport it's an international airport
it's a master plan Community it has a
couple of Blue Ribbon Schools you come
here and the roads are super nice and
you see the exact same thing in places
like Houston which I just was like La
Sienna or Sugarland it feels just the
same way and so you can tell like oh
wait Irvine isn't the only Irvine or
Apollos Verdes or Arcadia isn't the only
Arcadia there's arcadias in every single
state now look at what you can afford
and the ones that haven't matched that
level and price it's gonna get there one
day and for us we got lucky that it got
there in a year yeah but um being able
to see the patterns so that you can see
like oh no one likes this so if no one
likes this
they're subconsciously going to look for
a solution yeah so if you can get to
that solution first
that's how you come up you know yeah you
sound like the chef going like easy just
how you make bread crumbs and everyone's
like uh what what do you what do you
mean yeah you're uh you're not a white
belt anymore dude that's Kenny yeah no
this is all super insightful stuff and I
hope that you know you guys can can take
away some of these gems but even if they
can't take it away from here at least
you gave resources as to who they can
listen to to start building up their uh
Financial portfolio yeah I literally
listen to them daily Graham Stefan
thatch minority mindset Dave Ramsey
um did I say one more person
you did uh Stan uh Graham Stephen oh
Graham Stefan model minority Dave Ramsey
bigger pocket Bigger Pockets yeah I love
bigger pie is one of the best real
estate uh podcasts out there
um shout out to David Green
um he's on most of them but they talk
about everything short-term rentals
long-term rentals you know like
everything real estate yeah everything
and then you get to like hear and go and
you hear and they bring on real guests
so you can hear people struggle oh that
doesn't sound like me oh that does sound
like me super red all right well uh
anything else you want to add no that's
it um I just hope that in the future we
can continue to keep building our
portfolio and our little family bank and
business and the more I learn the more
I'm gonna pass on to you guys because I
want everyone to succeed yeah and build
that generational wealth everyone keeps
talking about yeah cool what about
barbell well barbell is always dropping
new [__] every month the time so make
sure you go to Barbara brigade.com
especially early June we got a sick ass
launch and then end of May we have a
sour gummy or pre-workout our
best-selling pre-workout restock and
also brown sugar bubble
brigade.com see you guys next time bye